[Music]
hi I'm Charles money I'm an executive
chef of Basha New York foundry cooking
is basically from the northern part of
India it's an Indian version of a
barbecue cooking this is one of the most
fresh and healthiest way of eating an
Indian food without a lot of curries
gravies or those things on barbecue is
one of the best way to enjoy the meat
basically it's get cooked very fast and
straight from oven to the plate to the
mouth nothing can go wrong without
people have a misperception about an
Indian food it's too much butter too
much oil too much a spicy food I want to
meet those kind of people and I want to
tell them there is another way to cook a
Indian food there's another way to enjoy
Indian food with a great flavors and my
customers are enjoying it the way we
start out on the rechecking is we like
to marinate that you can overnight the
marination is a little bit of different
way than a regular way of Indian cooking
we use the Mavi nation of the ginger
garlic paste sour cream a little bit of
chili powder paprika garam masala and
little bit of citrus we marinated
overnight basically if we allow the
chicken to observe the complete
marination and then we are gonna cook it
for like 15 minutes maximum
Thunder ramen is basically the clay oven
so we cook the Thunder we products in a
two different way Derek heat and
indirectly play is getting hot so you're
getting heat from the clay and then
chocolate gives them its smoky flavor
and freshness every time we fry
something it loses some of the favor
in the oil so the advantage of the
tandoori cooking is everything stays in
the meat and then you get to enjoy
hundred-person of the flavor that's a
basic way of how we're cooking out under
a chicken here
I started my career in South India
that's where I'm from
I'm from Chennai when I was working in
India I didn't had much opportunity to
cook Indian food but I had the basic
knowledge of the Indian food I grew up
eating Indian food from the time when I
was a baby
rather than fathering some of the
recipes I wanted to create something on
my own that's how I inspired all the
dishes what we have in front of us so
it's our own twist for me is cooking is
like a it's fascinating when I see
people enjoy it makes me happy so every
time I'm happy I try to come up with
something new so I pay complete
attention to each and every dish over
here in Basha
[Music]
[Applause]